homes crushed in a Russian missile
strike far away from the front line
at least five people died and many more
were injured including children
Horror in denipro was condemned
Conde Crane's president
who stressed the need for more powerful
Western weapons to help his troops win
Britain earned a special mention foreign
this is the kind of weapon he has in
mind the UK's Challenger two main battle
tank pictured here exercising in Estonia
in his phone call with Vladimir zelenski
Rishi sunak pledged to give some to
Ukraine
the number is small about a dozen but
the move is significant marking the
first time Ukrainian troops will receive
Western tanks it shows that we are now
Less risk-averse in a grading our
support for Ukraine less spooked I
suppose by uh Putin's rhetoric that any
serious Western involvement could have
repercussions in the war might
dangerously escalate Russia was quick to
issue a warning saying bringing tanks to
the conflict Zone far from drawing the
hostilities to a close will only serve
to intensify combat operations
one of those most wary about escalation
is this man Germany's chancellor Olaf
Schultz on a visit to Kiev last year
yet he's under growing pressure to allow
german-made tanks to join the fight
it's not a done deal yet but the UK has
just made it a bit harder for Berlin to
say no debraham Sky News